[Music]
don't forget to enter our amazon gift
card giveaway all you have to do is like
the video and comment
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about the night king's master plan
theory of mine that i shared with you on
this channel over a year ago
it's about the night king not
participating in battle for winnefell
but actually using his army as a decoy
to accomplish bigger and better plan
which would be adding 1 million people
the population of king's landing to his
army
this is a classic game of thrones move
in season 2 rob stark gives a huge blow
to the lancer army
when he surprises jaime by sending 2 000
of his men to death to fight timing
when he expected all 20 000 and then
sends the other 18 000 to jaime
defeating and capturing him in season 7
jaime pulls off the exact same move with
castley rock and highgarden
i think the night king is going to do
the same in winterfell and go straight
towards king's landing with his dragon
the night king is not stupid and he
knows that bringing his dragon into
battle for winterfell will result with
viserion's final death
all it takes for dany or john is to fly
their dragons to viserion and burn him
down
but even one well-placed dreamless arrow
would do the job
viserion will definitely not be at
winnefell and nor will the night king
i think we might see the night king in
the very beginning of episode 3 at
winterfell
but i believe he will then back out and
will not be seen until the end of an
episode
when he will see him fly his dragon to
king's landing and that's how the
episode ends
as most of us know for the final season
of game turns the production for the
very first time instead of filming his
laning scenes in jubronic
they decided to make a huge king's
landing set in belfast so why did they
build city buildings to resemble the
city they used for king's landing all
these years
instead of filming at actual medieval
old towns as they usually do
that's because game of thrones is not
allowed to burn the cities to the ground
as construction for king's landing set
focused on polishing the city walls
inside the set streets a famous jubronic
landmark has been faithfully reproduced
the most notable are the city gates and
king's landing dome
however the set has been modified to
appear burned down with a huge bridge
between demolished towers
the city gate has been obliterated and
the towers that once protected it have
fallen
the lannister banners then once the door
the walls are gone
king's laning dome has been burned down
this is the final confirmation
the capital is most definitely going to
fall and a big portion of it is going to
burn down in the final season
and as speculated for months now the
main suspect behind it all is the dragon
who was also spotted on this set
yes dragons are visual effects magic
mostly however when performers have to
interact with dragons a number of
methods are used to make it work
for example if dany has to touch the
jungle's head any dragon head shaped
object will do
this was when dragons were small this is
the night king touching viserion's head
in the last season
for flying scenes emilia clarke uses the
dragon-shaped buck
which most in all the ways says vendi's
directed interface
if actors have to actually mount a
dragon part of its spine has to be
physically recreated
which is exactly what this massive
contraption is king's landing said being
burned down means that either the night
king
viserion or dany with drogon will at one
point decide to burn down the capital
this massive contraption being on this
very same set means that once again
neither dany or the night king will at
some point decide to land in king's
landing
now that we know for cern that the
capital will fall at some point let's
see how it could actually go down
these leagues could be a confirmation of
a theory of mine regarding the night
king and his master plan
in that theory i explained you how all
main characters in game tournaments says
velazzola's fans expect a great battle
to be fought in the north
on a front defined by the advanced army
of the dead and partly we are correct
the north will face a hundred thousand
strong army of white walkers and their
whites
but the night king will fly viserion to
the far south across the whole westeros
and will raise the dead thus the entire
continent will be facing a horde of
whites overnight
this theory of mine has not only been
foreshadowed multiple times throughout
the show but it's also supported with a
few visions from the future that are yet
to come true
the shadow of a dragon flying over
king's landing and the one in which
brain sees king's landing in winter with
an empty throne room that has its roof
blown off
the same one then is saw in the house of
the undying basically the night king
will create a huge army in the south
while sacrificing his current
army in the north but let's get a bit
back in the season 7 finale starts to
reveal to jaime that euron only
pretended to be heading back to pike out
of fear
making her actually sell to essos to
hire the gunner company and to bring
nemeth his own fleet to westeros to
serve under her
commands this is not coming as a huge
surprise since in the fourth episode of
the season
cersei revealed her intentions to take
out a new loan from the iron bank to
hire the golden company
to expand her armies with their help
cersei will take the advantage of the
war between the living and the dead
and would try to retrieve the lands that
are currently taken away from her
basically while the living or fighting
the dead cersei will try to as she calls
it to achieve kingdoms that belong to
her with a mercenary organization
in the far north on the other hand the
night king has brought down a large
section of the wall at eastwatch
allowing his army to march south and by
episode 3 he arrives at vanerfell
while the most of westeros has agreed to
unite and send their forces north
to fight against the only enemy that
matters so we all expect the great war
to take place in the north
and we'll expect cersei to quietly
rebuild her power while the fighting
happens elsewhere
well we might be wrong now that the
night king is in possession of a dragon
and no longer has to worry about the
wall he'll most likely cause devastation
across the whole westeros
not only the north the night king can
now fly anywhere in westeros relatively
quickly
and he can raise the dead not only is
this a place where people in most cases
don't burn the dead
but due to the recent wars ravaging
westeros there are plenty of corpses
laying in mass graves
as i already said all the main
characters expect the great battle to be
fought in the north
on a front defined by the advanced army
of the dead then partly they are correct
the north will face a hundred thousand
strong army white walkers and the rights
of winterfell
but the night king will fly this area to
the far south across the whole westeros
and will raise the dead
thus the entire continent will be facing
a horde of whites overnight
while prophecies in game of thrones
don't literally come true visions on the
other hand do
we know this for a fact is in the sixth
episode of the sixth season
after mira flees the cave with brain
brain received multiple visions of past
and future events
and one of his visions for the future
already came true in the season 6 finale
bran's vision of the exploding wildfire
already came true as cersei and qyburn
used it four episodes later to destroy
the great scepter bailor with the
majority of her enemies
the remaining two visions from the
future that are yet to capture are the
shadow of a dragon flying over king's
landing
and the one in which bran sees king's
landing winter with an empty throne room
that has its roof blown off
at first glance this would imply that
dany does end up reaching and taking
over king's landing eventually
but the crumbled building the red keep
and burnt houses with the military
background are of the major importance
then he would not destroy the red keep
in which the iron tron is
nor would she burn down houses where
innocent people live as proven in
numerous season 7 scenes
the damage done to the red cape and to
the houses however is consistent with
something that danish dragons would be
able to do
the main suspect being her dead dragon
viserion
this brands visions one of which danny
had as well along with leaked photos in
which we can see that big portion of
king's landing will at some point be
burned down pretty much confirmed my
statement that the united king will fly
visiting to the far south
and raise the dead across the whole
westeros thus leaving cersei's plan
quite a bit ruined and also surprising
the entire living side
some would think that this army would be
destroyed once it comes across
winterfell
but leaked photos seem to prove
otherwise upon suffering a tremendous
defeat by the current army of the dead
johnson of danny and crew will retreat
south to dragonstone
as it's been confirmed by season 8
theaters however they will then learn
that the night king has formed an even
bigger army of the dead in the south
bran stark will inform them that the
night king is marching his new army on
king's landing
upon learning this jon snow dany and the
entire living side will decide to go to
the capital
to face the great and the final battle
and thus help cersei defend it
since it's the largest city with a
population of 1 million innocent people
cersei's plan at this point is to
welcome the living side into the capital
and pretend to agree that they shall
face the common enemy together
cersei's plan is to wait in the red keep
for the army of the dead to breach the
city malls
and for the great battle to take place
inside a capital
cersei would then burn older enemies the
living and dead using wildfire
it's still unknown that cersei is aware
that there's caches of wildfire under
the red keep
even though it would not be surprising
if she does when faced with defeats her
simos certainly would not hesitate to
blow up king's landing
even if it means she would die as well
don't forget that when it appeared that
stannis was winning the battle for
king's landing cersei was ready to kill
herself
along with her child will cersei manage
to pull it off and burn everyone down
even though burn king's landing set
would seem to support this theory the
answer is no
wildfire is not the reason king's
landing set is being burned down
it's dragonfire how do i know it's
simply due to a fact that the show built
a king's landing set mainly to do live
pyrotechnics
it means that some parts of the capital
will be burned down by a dragon
as dragon fire in game of thrones is
portrayed by live biotechnics
basically cersei's plan to have the
living and the dead fight inside king's
landing will come true
but her burning them all with wildfire
will not and i think it could have
something to do with her brother jaime
lannister
who already saved the city from wildfire
before jaime is saved king's laning from
the mad king
will he be the one to save it from the
mad queen as well maybe
one is cern huge portion of king's
landing will be burned down by a dragon
in the final season
and it will most likely be caused by the
night king and his dragon
in conclusion i believe that the night
king will use his current army in
episode 3 as a decoy
while he'll actually fly out his dragon
to the far south and raise the dead
across soul of westeros
and then attack king's landing with his
new bigger army and he will destroy it
all divisions seem to be supporting it
and so do the season 8 league photos
let me know your thoughts about all of
this in the comment section down below
and as always i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our channel and i hope
to see you in the next one
peace
you